yesterday the mayor of Baltimore
Maryland announced the city will help
students get to the March for our lives
that gun-control rally in Washington
later this month it is all about hearing
the voices of young people and so we're
taking 60 buses Baltimore City because
we want your voices to be heard in
Washington DC joining us now is the
mayor of Baltimore Catherine Pugh who
supported and addressed hundreds of
students who walked out of their
classrooms yesterday demanding gun
control legislation mayor it is great to
have you on the show
I so appreciate your time tonight tell
us about what your goal is here in
Baltimore this March is going to take
place in a few weeks in Washington but
what do you want to achieve by helping
this helping the students go down so
first let me say thank you Laura for
this invite and it's good to be here
this evening with you so our goal is to
allow the young people's voices to be
heard
we didn't even know the young people
were marching down to City Hall but when
we did hear that they were coming I
thought it was important to receive them
because when you have these many young
people who are afraid and frightened to
be in their classrooms who are asking
you to help them go out and want to have
you hear their voices I mean they did
not necessarily even know about the
march in Washington some of them but
many of them wanted their voices to be
heard in terms of the violence that's
happening in our city in our country and
throughout this nation and so they want
their voices to be heard and we thought
it was important to address them to
welcome them and at the same time we
were being reached out as a city close
to Washington asking if we would be
interested in helping young people to
get to Washington DC so that their
voices could be heard as relates to gun
violence in this country and as you all
know we've had some 320 different school
shootings since 2013 and when young
people are asking you are you protecting
our schools are you protecting us are
you going to make sure we're safe
and just in our state alone our governor
has issued additional resources to help
schools to become more safe right you
have 343 murders in Baltimore and 2017
absolutely devastated devastating number
horrific violence have some of the
toughest gun laws in the country and
Maryland we all know that I don't know
if we have some of the toughest on them
to November December January February
we're actually trending and downward
internal that's good because our city's
very happy about that mayor let's go
through what's happening to the
Baltimore split in the Baltimore school
system because you you're your funding
60 buses to go down to the the March
it's gonna be a big fund s be divided by
the private sector as well as some kinda
Jews who are donating money so they're
make sure that on a Saturday morning
when young people want to go to
Washington DC but I think yes sure that
there you have to do that and to be able
to do that safely okay right the
Baltimore schools I don't know if you
know that but it's not working here
right the the Baltimore school system
here's some statistics the enrollment is
falling now to a ten-year low we have a
hundred and thirty million dollar budget
deficit I don't know what that has to do
with the number of young people I mean
oh boy you don't want the children back
to school but I'm gonna be my active all
right and having their voice we heard I
just worked for a long time it was a
young people who are very concerned he
and your classy 38 million needed for
HVAC and other repairs so 115 school
personnel later first time we've had
teacher layoffs Washington ten years
hopefully when they get to Washington DC
they'll be able to express that interest
as well okay we I understand that sports
America interest I'd like you are city
with all due respect merit like it
answer this questions
mayor mayor is the colossal Laura my
question is is any Laura you are you are
suffering in Baltimore as many other
metropolitan areas are as well it's not
unique to Baltimore but nevertheless
you're suffering from declining
enrollment you're suffering from a huge
Bo
deficit while your office is adding
we're not talking from the 20 staffers
deficit 130 million dollar budget
deficit for education in this fiscal
year yeah well that's not our entire
city budget so I thought no no your
schools we're talking about your your
funding buses the entire to go down to
Washington and you have a bunch and
everything you're Landry love I don't
know whether you're trying to become the
communications director for the Trump
administration I don't know why you're
getting your cell there I don't know how
you're getting or not funding we are
providing assistance to young people to
make sure that they get to Washington DC
safely but why is that your job your job
as the mayor of Baltimore to assist
students are you doing that for the
market for life January that's exactly
the reason why I'm doing it because I am
the mayor of my city because I care
about my children I want their voices
okay and we're going to make sure that
their voices are heard in Washington DC
have you done that for the March for
live every excited have you done that
know that that role lives in March every
January actually the pro-lifers didn't
reach out to me the you know you would
find them next day and you're in our
country the city the children of our
city of our country reached out to me
they came down and we offer to assist
them so that they can get to Washington
okay so you're not spending any money
because $100,000 because I have too many
assault weapons in this country we have
too many children being killed it's not
going to have too many people being
killed in the streets of our city so
we're excited for them and really are
you there are you concerned about the
fact that 13 of the 19 Baltimore high
schools have zero students today who are
meeting great proficiency every single
individual who lives in my city I'm
concerned about our schools I'm
concerned about the fear that exist
among young people in this country is a
bigger problem you know there's not a
bigger problem than training student
active there is no bigger problem than
having people killed by assault weapons
in this country there's no bigger
problem than parents who see the current
sees young people being killed there's
no bigger problem than people's lives
being located so yes weapons Americans
on the streets of all ages
understand that state and in our country
as the mayor to make sure and we want to
make sure that that doesn't happen we
want to make sure that this country
understands I got it that violence is
not the biotic assault weapons should
not be given to people and background
checks need to be done so when some
married just so our audience understands
in the future since do you think this is
important for students voices to be
heard
if conservative students pro-life is a
question please if if pro-life students
go to you and ask you to provide
transportation or support for attending
conservative marches because they want
their voices heard will you as mayor of
Baltimore support those efforts as well
in the education process or just for the
students let's be real clear if the
private sector wants to provide buses
for individuals to go protest anything
in York in this country they are willing
to support that just like the NRA
supports all of their okay so you're not
spending any money on people to have
their voices heard in this country Mesa
Mayor you think no money is being able
to go I'm funny money spent to make sure
that our young people get to Washington
DC okay so that's my question
government money the buses you guys
you're bleeding teacher teachers are
being fired personnel are being laid on
them you're hot you just hired 20 new
people including a new marketing
director in your office which is great
I'm sure they're gonna do a great job
we're getting teachers laid off
personnel laid off when you're shuttling
students that's where Helene is willing
to move are 22 people to take care of
the homeless on our streets retire in a
marketing director care of our
neighborhoods and our communities no we
did not a public that story's wrong -
there's a lot of nothing Thank You
Marilee that's that's not true you're
not spending you know know about they're
not getting a larger time on on
television stations on radio station air
and no questions I guess so that I could
share with you right it's happening in
Baltimore we're very safe Baltimore has
been under liberal leadership
how many years Washington DC and we hope
that you'll be there so that you can
welcome them there and you can hear
their voices I'm commanding barons at
Merrill young in there the problems in
Baltimore have been going on for years
and years and years my Liberal
leadership country it's not double
tracks Baltimore has high murder
Baltimore spot I think you brought that
action I'll try to bring up the issue of
Donald Trump I'm talking about Baltimore
City and now you know how to target
children whose voices one record right
though we don't really like to learn
what they make sure we want to make sure
that you're the only thing you're
teaching them is pretty good want to
make sure that assault we'll see how
this works out we want to make sure that
no more than code writers and writers
needed but we're gonna send them down to
protocol for 300 300 shootings in our
sliding rules right and that's in the
Nash is the fault of Maryland government
but not the fault of the National
Governors cons of liberal policies
having their hands and I may want to
call it liberal but we took we talking
the city protection consortium running
the city we want to make sure that our
country is safer we want background oh
yeah well we want your wanna go we wanna
be safer don't spend a lot of time late
at night on the streets along should be
21 years of age and we're gonna make
sure okay Mary we appreciate it it is
safe and we look forward to seeing you I
look forward to seeing you at the March
let's say let me say I'll go to that
March if you come to the March for Life
that's a good that's a good deal all
right we're out of time there it's just
not gonna stop talking